with Elden Ring's first DLC looming
right around the corner hopefully I
think it's important to note that more
than likely none of our questions
regarding the lore of Elden ring will be
answered when the DLC does release I can
almost guarantee that yes some of our
questions might get some additional
information but I believe will be left
with way more questions than overall
answers which sounds like a lot of fun
to me as an Elden ring lore theorist
which I've been kind of bad at as of
late I like to think and look outside
the box when coming up with video topics
which has been pretty helpful and
unhelpful in different ways I think it's
time to get back into the Elden ring
Theory workflow and start making videos
again some topics might be obscure some
might just be more General but all I
know is that the content is coming there
is no shortage of topics to discuss in
Elden ring this will be the last time I
address anything to you guys of what you
can expect from the channel in terms of
changes to the content or anything like
that you're here for the lore so that's
what you're going to get on this channel
from here on out if you're interested in
something different from myself check
out my second Channel which will be
linked down in the description with all
that said let's give joy some tummy rubs
on our way to 100 000 subscribers and
talk about Ronnie's Secret Mentor Rena
the snow witch
this way tarnished may I have a
home theater
I am the witch Rena
I'd heard tale of a tarnished hook in
about Atop A spectral Steed I was
entrusted this for thee Torrance former
Master tisabel for calling forth Spirits
now it is dying
to do it as thou wishest
forgive mine intrusion tarnished I doubt
we shall again meet
but all the same learn well the lands
between
how long will it be I wonder before the
tarnished Tire of a basins to the two
fingers so this interaction with who we
know at this time as Rena is one of my
favorite moments in the game at first
she sort of instructs us to come talk to
her making sure that no one else is able
to hear our conversation with her even
putting kale and his donkey to sleep as
she talks to us but she quickly changes
from an instructive tone at first to a
more approachable one and then
immediately lies to our face she
introduces herself as the witch Rena now
I feel the need to mention this because
I still receive a good amount of
comments suggesting that Rena and Ronnie
are the same person but if you still
believe this you're wrong but also
technically half right but if you made
it far enough into the game to find the
karian manor you can meet with her again
where she tells us her real name and
what her goals are oh
again we cross paths I believe I said my
name was Rena well last we met
pleaseth me to see torrent Hale and
Hearty I am the witch Ronnie
I stole death long ago I'll search now
for the dark path
that I might one day upend the whole of
it
and rid the world of all that came
before now if you're watching this video
you're probably a die-hard Elder ring
fan but most people who once played
Elden ring have stopped after their
first playthrough they didn't end up
researching more topics or lore
discussions on the game so it's very
possible that there's a very good amount
of players who never met Ronnie outside
of their interaction with her in the
Church of Ella it's also entirely
possible that they never had this
interaction with her either so it does
make sense that some players would be a
bit confused about this and when they do
come across a video saying something
different from what they once thought
they might comment that confusion
everyone's Journey Through the lands
between is different which will lead
them to different outlooks on the
discoveries that they find throughout
the game Elden ring was clearly
intentionally designed to do this the
second most suggested argument that I
see in the comments to who Rana is is
that Rena is the short for ranala who we
know is Ronnie's mother Ronaldo was a
powerful sorceress of magic she led the
glidstone knights and established the
house of carya along with being the head
of Raya lucaria Academy however after
radagon left Renault to become the
second Elden Lord in King consort to
Queen America her heart was broken after
this the rest of the academy realized
that Ronaldo was no longer the powerful
being that she once was so they locked
her away in the grand library to do with
as she wished with radagon's last gift
to her I'm bringing all of this up to
point out that renala was widely known
throughout the lands between an
influential powerful and beautiful
figure before her heart was broken and
she was locked away if we read the
description of the snow which said that
Ronnie wears it tells us that it was
once worn by the snowy Crone who the
young Ronnie encountered deep in the
woods she was a witch and well-versed in
cold sorceries it is said that the doll
that houses Ronnie's Soul was modeled
after her this is what I meant earlier
when I said you'd be Technic quickly
half right if you think Ronnie's
character is Rena Ronnie isn't in her
real body but her spirit has taken over
the doll that has been modeled after a
snowy Crone who she met in the woods
that we can assume from the item
description is Rena now getting back to
the Rena is Ronaldo argument I highly
doubt that Ronnie would encounter her
own mother deep in the woods I also
highly doubt that her own mother would
also be Ronnie's Secret Mentor as it
also says in the snow which set item
description this also tells us that
Ronnie's doll is modeled more than
likely after Rena which is a far stretch
obviously from what ranala looks like I
know it's much more simple to think Rena
is just short for ranala you literally
can't spell ranala without Rena
unfortunately I don't think this is that
simple right now is just someone who has
either died before our time in the lands
between or someone we haven't met yet
which is why I really hope Elden Rings
DLC involves going back in time to see
the lands between and meet with all
these ancient characters before the
shattering unfolded Ronaldo's boss fight
has two different phases the first is
ranala in her more recent form where her
heart is broken and she is obsessed with
the rebirthing properties of her beloved
egg given to her by her now ex-husband
radagon the second stage is a trap set
by Ronnie herself as she summons
ranala's true power upon my name is
Ronnie the witch
[Music]
mother's Rich limber shall not be
disturbed by thee
foul trespasser
send word far and wide
[Music]
of the last queen of Korea
granola of the full moon
[Music]
and the Majesty of the night she
conjureth once we defeat Ronnie's trap
we can find Ronaldo cradling her egg
completely unharmed if we go on from
here to talk to Ronnie and her Tower he
won't mention anything about her mother
I believe that Ronnie set this trap in
order to protect her mother but it was
likely a very long time ago that she did
possibly even before the night of black
knives or she just isn't able to tell
that her trap was triggered yet this
spell clearly tells us that Ronnie
wishes to protect her mother and show
the world what she was truly capable of
at one point ranala's heartbreak most
likely happened well before the night of
black knives with Ronnie's mother now
heartbroken and true power gone she
might have needed a new teacher and
Mentor I believe this is where she met
Rena the snow witch deep in the woods of
leernia lakes and this is all we know
about Rena unfortunately and from this
point forward it would all be
speculation I do believe however that
Rena in influence Ronnie to orchestrate
and plan the Knight of black knives
which if we think about the overall
timeline of events Ronnie stole death a
very long time ago potentially thousands
of years ago she shed her own imperian
flesh to get rid of the two fingers
influence over her to do this she needed
to slay her own two fingers now I made a
video on this a few months back on a
theory that Ronnie's brother radon found
out about her plan to kill her own two
fingers and since radon was still
devoted to the golden order he used his
gravity magic to lift Ronnie's two
fingers into space so she couldn't
complete her plan this is what they mean
by Ronnie's fate being Guided by the
stars and why you need to defeat radon
in order to set her fate back into
motion the Stars alter the fate of the
Korean royal family
and the fate of your mistress Rani but
long ago General radon challenged the
swirling constellations
and in a crushing Victory arrested their
Cycles now he is the force that repulses
the Stars if General radon were to Die
the Stars would resume their movement
and so too would rani's Destiny when you
kill radon we set the stars that he was
holding back into motion once again a
shooting star falls from the sky to open
up the entrance to nocron so you can get
the Finger Slayer blade that Ronnie
needs to kill her own two fingers I
believe her two fingers also crash
landed where we can find Ronnie and her
now slain two fingers at the end of her
questline and if we choose Ronnie's
ending I believe this Dark Moon Ronnie
creates is actually a portal or waygate
to another world entirely potentially
hopefully back in time it's been shown
to us that time travel is possible when
entering the dragonlord fight in
faramazula so I wonder where from
software plans to take this potential
for time travel from here on out but if
anything the similarities between these
gates in Ronnie's moon during her ending
are too similar to ignore so why do I
say that Rena was a part of this plan
well if Rena was important enough to
Ronnie for her to take control of a doll
constructed from the likeness of Rena
after sacrificing her real body then
Rena must have been a part of this plan
in some way how big of an influence
that's impossible to say at this point
but I find the intentions of these
powerful demigods and the Allies they
choose to join their alliances to be the
true questions that can lead to the most
answers intent is important in Elden
Ring's characters and its overall story
because sometimes what we intend doesn't
always result in what we want
well then
shall we
[Music]